What we want to do is build this map of
the solar system. So what does that mean
in a modern day and age? Well, first off, in order to know where the
asteroids are now, what I need to do is
I gotta build telescopes. I need to
observe an asteroid and I need to watch
it move for some period of time so I can
figure out what its orbit is. And then I
need to have math, and I need to
understand orbital mechanics and I can
calculate the the trajectory of that one
particular asteroid. And now I
need to repeat by a million times.
There's a million or so asteroids.
And I need to
update these things. So the first thing
you need to build a really good map
at the solar system is telescopes.
Now this isn't that much different than
how we map the surface of the earth.
we had spy satellites which
became commercial satellites looking
down at the earth. But the original
ones were built by governments. And that
data was held secret and tightly held,
eventually became open and eventually
became publicly available. And a couple
of companies were able to take these
publicly available information and make
really good use of it different than the
way the CIA analyst and those types of
folks looked at things. They built things
that were usable. They built Google Earth.
They built Google Maps. They built MapQuest. What we
want to do is follow that same tack. We
want to take data from these telescopes -
and these are some interesting
telescopes - the one up there is one
called Pan-STARRS. It's in Hawaii, and
it's on the top of Maui. And it is the
current most powerful telescope for
finding and tracking asteroids on Earth. The
one in the middle is one called the
Large Synoptic Survey Telescope. It is going to be the world's largest
survey telescope for finding asteroids
and looking into the formation and
evolution of the universe. That
is being built currently in Chile by the
National Science Foundation for about
700 million dollars and it becomes
operational in
two and a half years. And so that
thing there is about 50 times more
powerful than this one. And so what's
going to happen here is that the
publicly available datasets - remember
this is paid for by the US government -
is going to explode.
There's going to be an enormous number
of new discoveries. Now, it's not going to
find all the asteroids we want to find,
but it's going to do a heck of a lot
better than anything out there right now.
So what it means is we're gonna have a lot
of data. What are we going to do with it?
How are we preparing to deal with this
data? How do we make that map out of this
data? Because really what this thing is
finding is not...it's not producing a map
anymore than Google Maps is the same as
a bunch of photographs of the earth
taken by spy satellites. Somebody had to
build a system that allows you to
navigate around and allows you to do
things like turn-by-turn directions,
you know, place my store here, that sort
of stuff. All those things are what made
Google Maps useful that's not been done
for the solar system for navigating to
asteroids, for calculating if an
asteroid might hit the earth, for
laying resource claims, for doing
deep-space navigation. All those things
are going to be services built on a map.
So maps are changing from
two-dimensional to four-dimensional and
they're changing from static objects to
services. And if you think about what
this map is going to be, it's going to be
a service. It's going to be something
that exists in computers that people can
access and use and build off of.